[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад, і ми продовжуємо
обговорювати роботу та кар'єру добре, як
ви отримали ці запитання, чи
потрібні вам гроші, чи чекаєте з нетерпінням,
ось оголошення про роботу, добре, ми всі
повинні бути незалежними  від інших наших
батьків або від інших дорослих, і
найкращий спосіб бути незалежним - це влаштуватися на
роботу, можливо, ви не можете працювати повний робочий день,
тому що ви студенти, але ви можете
знайти роботу на неповний робочий день, давайте
подивимося на оголошення, які вони є
британські веб-сайти, і
діти справді претендують на ці вакансії,
але перш ніж ми почнемо, давайте трохи
потренуємося зі словником, тож у нас
є слова зліва,
вони готівка. Я навчаю мене балакучий
цінний кар'єра та кваліфікований і правий
у вас є визначення, витратьте хвилину,
щоб прочитати визначення, а потім
будьте готові знайти відповідність між словом і
визначенням, щоб ми отримали балакучий, який
має особливі здібності або навчає
неформальне слово для грошей, дуже корисне або
важливе, ніж  II людина, яку
навчають виконувати роботу та
обрану людиною роботу та роботу в житті добре, хлопці,
ви готові знайти відповідність першому, а
перший — готівка, тому готівка — це неофіційне
слово для грошей, коли я кажу, що мені потрібні
гроші  це означає, що мені потрібні гроші, добре,
наступний я навчаю мене,
будь ласка, вимова та стресовий
стажер під who's a trainee Я стажер
- це людина, яку навчають виконувати
роботу, наприклад, ви хочете стати
перукарем і спочатку ви  будьте
стажером і тільки закінчите, ви почнете
працювати перукарем
добре наступний балакучий до діаграми ви знаєте
це слово і прикметник балакучий
балакучий означає балакучий
вона балакуча людина вона багато говорить
вона балакуча людина він багато говорить
наступне слово цінне
означає дуже корисне та важливе, наприклад,
ви можете сказати, що ця інформація є цінною,
або ви можете сказати, що ця інформація
корисна та важлива, будь ласка, вивчіть
синоніми, вони роблять вашу мову яскравішою,
добре наступне слово  це знову кар'єра
розум вимова наша кар'єра і
кар'єра - це обрана людиною робота і робота всього
життя добре, тому моя робота полягає в тому, щоб навчити
вас англійської мови, а моя кар'єра - це вчитель,
добре, а останній вбитий, а
бути кваліфікованим означає мати особливе
здібності або підготовка добре ще раз
перегляньте ці слова та визначення, які вам
знадобляться під час цього уроку, давайте
продовжимо зараз, давайте подивимося на
оголошення, тож перший із них —
працівник служби підтримки, щоб підтримати означає допомогти, давайте
прочитаємо опис роботи,
чи є у вас  здатність піклуватися про
інших чи можете ви зрозуміти, як літні
люди відчувають, що мені потрібен хороший комунікатор,
чи маєте ви гарні навички слухання чи можете
ви добре працювати у вихідні дні з цього опису роботи
ми можемо дізнатися, що ця людина має
бути дійсно турботливою та відповідальною, добре,
давайте продовжимо, якщо  ви відповіли «так»
на все вищезазначене, ми хотіли б почути
від вас початкову ставку вісім фунтів
п’ятдесят шість фунтів на годину безкоштовної форми
та відмінного навчання, якщо ви хочете
щоб заробляти таку суму грошей за годину,
і якщо ви піклуєтеся про інших, це може
бути хорошим для вас,
добре, а потім ви можете побачити
назву компанії golden Kia і ви
побачите електронний лист, в якому написано, що кар'єри в golden -
care calm  добре, це перший,
давайте подивимося на другого,
стажер-перукар, чи пам’ятаєте ви
про Triny triny, це людина, яка все
ще навчається для роботи, тому вона працює
повний робочий день, 40 годин на тиждень, постійний
центр міста Брайтон, навчайтеся у деяких
з  найкращі перукарі світу -
це хороша можливість як літня робота,
тому що влітку вам не потрібно
ходити до школи, щоб ви могли витратити 40 годин на
роботу та навчання для нової роботи, добре,
давайте прочитаємо опис, ви будете працювати
40 годин  тиждень з понеділка по суботу у ваші
обов’язки входитиме вітати
клієнтів, мити волосся, приносити клієнтам каву чи
чай, а також підтримувати камеру,
а також постійно підтримувати чистоту й порядок
. Це багато роботи, але найкраща
вигода, яку я бачу, це те  Ви
зможете вчитися у найкращих
перукарів світу, якщо ви бачите
себе в кар’єрі
перукаря
, це хороша можливість, добре,
і останні підсумки говорять, що попередній
досвід не потрібен, будь ласка, подайте заявку зараз,
щоб вони наймали зараз, і це
хороший вибір для тих, у кого немає
досвіду роботи, їм він не потрібен, і
знову ви можете побачити електронну пошту, з якою ви можете
зв'язатися з ними, добре, наступною роботою
будуть автори журналів, потрібні хлопці, можливо,
ви добре пишете, можливо, ваші дописи
привертайте багато уваги в Instagram, і
вас дійсно цікаво, щоб вас читали настільки
добре, що ми шукаємо письменників
для свого веб-сайту, оплата залежить від
кількості людей, які читають ваші статті,
тому якщо у вас багато передплатників у
вашому Instagram і  сотні людей
читають ваші дописи, можливо, це хороший
варіант для вас, ви також можете отримувати безкоштовні
квитки на події та безкоштовні продукти, щоб
протестувати Вау, безкоштовні квитки на концерти
ваших улюблених груп
, це чудово  мураха на безкоштовних продуктах, щоб
перевірити дівчат, можливо, трохи макіяжу чи
одягу чудова можливість добре, і
це чудова можливість отримати цінний
досвід роботи, щоб працювати у великому
журналі чи працювати у великій компанії,
навіть на невеликій посаді, це чудова робота
досвід, тому ми хочемо людей, які
балакучі, цікаві пристрасні та
вправні, тож якщо ви балакучий, якщо ви
любите багато говорити,
тоді цей журнал безперечно для вас,
і знову у вас є контактний дріт,
електронна пошта, наступний, який дзвонить старим
моделям
Ну, багато підлітків сьогодні хочуть
стати моделями, тому подумайте, що ви могли б бути
моделлю,
так чому б ні, якщо так, ми хотіли б познайомитися з вами
працювати успішною
фотомоделлю непросто, але це дуже захоплююче і
може бути чудовою можливістю, безперечно,
це  зовсім непросто,
але хороша можливість, тож давайте подивимося, чи
підходить вам дівчатам старше 16 років, добре,
більшість із вас старше 16 років і мінімальний
зріст 172 сантиметри, це
досить висока людина, а хлопці повинні
мати мінімальний зріст  Висота 182 сантиметри,
дійсно високі хлопці, якщо вам ще не виповнилося 16 років і
ще не маєте необхідного зросту, ми
все одно були б зацікавлені в зустрічі з вами,
але ви повинні привести своїх батьків добре, тому
це означає, що якщо вам ще 15, а
ви ще ні  Зріст 172 або 182 сантиметри,
ви все одно можете прийти, можливо, ви будете
хорошою моделлю ще через кілька років, тому
я знову отримав електронний лист, щоб зателефонувати в
компанію,
так що останній працює на кавові зерна
і приєднується до кафе номер один у Британії  у
кавових зернах, де кожне кафе має
однакові цілі: створити сімейні команди
та забезпечити відмінне обслуговування клієнтів,
це означає, що це величезна мережа
кафе з набором стандартів, яких вони дотримуються
в кожному кафе, тому багато різних
людей приходять і працюють  з нами, тому почніть
свою кар’єру в кавових зернах сьогодні,
оберіть години роботи, отримайте досвід керування,
поділіться своєю любов’ю до кави та
приєднайтеся до нас як
помічник менеджера або менеджера кафе
залежно від ваших навичок та досвіду,
щоб вони надали  не лише одна робота, але
вони пропонують три посади, чудовий вибір,
і знову ви можете побачити електронну пошту,
хлопці, ми прочитали кілька оголошень про вакансії, а
тепер давайте виконаємо кілька завдань, щоб у вас були
їхні люди, у вас є ці вакансії, і
ви повинні порекомендувати людину  робота,
тому перша людина - Ніна, а Ніна
вивчає англійську мову і має власний блог,
вона дуже комунікабельна людина,
цікавиться музикою та модою,
добре товариська, значить, вона любить говорити,
вона балакуча, якщо вона вивчає англійську, вона
вміє добре писати і більше того  у неї є
свій блог, тож яку роботу ви б
порекомендували Ніні добре, безперечно, це буде ми,
автор журналу
добре, хлопці, гарно спробуйте, давайте продовжимо
наступною людиною є Дейв, тому Джейн щойно
закінчила школу і шукає
роботу на
повний робочий день, це означає, щоб  працює від дев'яти до
п'яти п'яти днів на тиждень
він комунікабельний він любить працювати своїми
руками і піклується про свій зовнішній вигляд Вау, робота
повний робочий день дбає про зовнішність
і добре володіє руками,
тому вони рекомендують роботу для Дава
Ви маєте рацію, хлопці, це стажер-
перукар, так,
наступна людина Девайн любить допомагати
людям, він хоче змінити
життя інших людей, він шукає
можливості дізнатися нові речі, які
допоможуть йому в кар'єрі,
це опис дуже турботливого  людина
та людина, яка готова до певної
відповідальності, тому рекомендована робота
для boge — допоміжний працівник, так,
наступна — Сара і Сара — студентка,
і вона шукає роботу на
неповний робочий день, вона не працює,
щоб працювати  в ресторані чи магазині не
для неї вона висока, красива і має
свій унікальний вигляд, якщо ти високий
і красивий і маєш свій власний
унікальний зовнішній вигляд, чому б не спробувати
бути гарною моделлю, це правильно, щоб вона
йшла  бути моделлю, можливо, наступний
Сем Сем доброзичливий і товариський, він має
досвід роботи в ресторані і
хоче працювати з більшою кількістю обов'язків, у
нього є певний досвід і він
готовий до більшого, він вивчає частину-  час,
тому йому потрібен гнучкий графік роботи.
Він був би хорошим вибором для
працівника кафе в кавових зернах, і вони пропонують
кілька варіантів, можливо, він може бути одним із
них добре, хлопці, ми можемо продовжити, тепер ви
повинні закінчити речення
буквами від А до Е  і, до речі, ви
можете використовувати кожну букву кілька разів, так що
будь-яка для допоміжного працівника, яловичина чи
сукня для стажерів - i
C для того, що ми пишемо, D для
Moodle і E для працівника кафе в кавових зернах,
тому першу вам ніколи не
доведеться  носите свій власний одяг на роботу ніколи
не ваш одяг, і насправді це
допоміжний працівник, тому що вони забезпечують
уніформу. Наступна одна робота або перші
можливості для дітей до 16
років,
як ви пам'ятаєте, робота підходить для
тих, кому ще не виповнилося 16 років і що  це
Moodle, але вам потрібно прийти з
батьками, наступна ваша плата за роботу
залежить від того, наскільки ви успішні на
роботі, якщо ви пам’ятаєте, що ми говорили про те, що втратили
наші дописи в Instagram, і це те, що ми
пишемо журналом  вам будуть платити більше, якщо
вас читатимуть більше, наступна робота
вимагає фізичного контакту з клієнтами,
і це означає, що вам доведеться
доторкнутися до клієнта або зробити щось із,
можливо, його волоссям чи обличчям, тож це буде пропозиція
роботи стажера-перукаря номер п’ять
Можливості управління та
можливості управління пропонувалися в
кафе в кавових зернах, а це варіант E,
ви можете отримати певну халяву, якщо виконуватимете
роботу за роботою C. Халява означають
певні переваги, і ці халяви були
якимось продуктом для тестування продукту
або мали отримати  квитки на деякі події,
гаразд,
наступна робота, яку вам потрібно буде тісно співпрацювати
зі своєю командою, це
кафе в кавових зернах, це командна робота,
а остання робота призначена для тих, хто любить
працювати з людьми похилого віку і, звісно,
поміжним працівником  варіант
добре, хлопці, тож ось вибір
різних робіт, і тепер ви готові
послухати про одну з робіт, які зазвичай
мають підлітки в західному світі, і
це робота няні  Якщо
це заповнення пропусків відрізняється,
зазвичай вам потрібно заповнити
пропуски лише одним словом, але під час цього прослуховування
вам доведеться заповнити пропуски
більш ніж одним словом, можливо, двома, можливо, трьома
словами, тому ви слухатимете, можливо,
двічі або  навіть три рази, але це
прослуховування триває лише одну хвилину, тому
перш за все, будь ласка,
перегляньте весь текст, щоб отримати
загальне уявлення про нього, а потім приготуйтеся
до прослуховування добре добре, хлопці, ви
готові слухати, тому слухайте та заповніть
прогалини няні
я любив няні, коли я був молодшим,
це був дуже простий спосіб заробити гроші,
все, що мені потрібно було зробити, це сидіти в
будинку сусіда і доглядати за дітьми, що
було легко, тому що діти
зазвичай спали в ліжку батьки
давав мені багато грошей за перегляд DVD-дисків
і закуски, коли я був ще
молодшим, мені подобалося, коли приходила моя няня,
вона завжди грала
з нами в ігри,
і дозволяла нам не спати допізна, вона посилала
нас спати перед моїми батьками  прийшов
додому, я знаю, що в деяких країнах
няня не так поширена, це не є
частиною культури, я вважаю, що це не
така вже й погана річ. Сьогодні я багато читаю в
газетах про те, що няня
б'є дітей, тому що вони не
сплять, це насправді  погано,
добре, хлопці, я сподіваюся, що ви заповнили
деякі прогалини, я не вважаю, що ви заповнили
їх усі, тому що є більше
одного слова добре,
зараз, чи не могли б ви, будь ласка, прочитати цей текст ще раз
і послухати вдруге,
будь ласка, нянька з ним,
я люблю  доглядати за дітьми, коли я був молодшим,
це був дуже простий спосіб заробити гроші,
все, що мені потрібно було зробити, це сидіти в будинку мого сусіда
і доглядати за дітьми, що
було легко, тому що діти
зазвичай спали в ліжку, батьки
давали мені багато  грошей за перегляд DVD-дисків
і закуски, коли я був ще
молодшим, мені подобалося, коли приходила моя няня,
вона завжди грала
з нами в ігри
і
дозволяла нам не спати допізна, вона відправляла нас
спати перед тим, як мої батьки повернулися додому, я
знаю, в деяких  граф  спроби няні - це не
так часто, це не частина культури, я
вважаю, що це не так вже й погано, я
багато читаю в газетах про те, що
няні б'ють дітей, тому що
вони не сплять, це дуже погано,
хлопці, це незвичайно  слухати,
тому, будь ласка, послухайте це
втретє, це не звичайна річ,
але цього разу ви можете няні.
Я любив няні, коли я був молодшим,
це був дуже простий спосіб заробити гроші,
усе, що мені потрібно було зробити, це сидіти в своєму  сусідський
будинок і доглядати за дітьми, це
було легко, тому що діти
зазвичай спали в ліжку, батьки
давали мені багато грошей за перегляд DVD-дисків
і закуски, коли я був ще
молодшим, мені подобалося, коли приходила моя няня
завжди грай
з нами в ігри, і дозволяй нам не спати допізна,
вона посилала нас спати перед тим, як мої
батьки повернулися додому, я знаю, що в деяких
країнах няня не так поширена,
це не частина культури, я вважаю,
що це не так вже й погано  я  Сьогодні багато читаю
в газетах про те, що
няня б'є дітей,
тому що вони не сплять, це дуже
погано, хлопці, я сподіваюся, що вам вдалося
заповнити прогалини, тепер давайте перевіримо я хочу, щоб
ви слідували за доповідачем і словами,
які ви повинні були  заповніть червоним кольором, тож
, будь ласка, перевірте, чи
слідкуйте за спікером ще раз добре
няня я любив няні, коли я
був молодшим, це був дуже простий спосіб
заробити гроші, усе, що мені потрібно було зробити, це сидіти в будинку мого
сусіда й дивитися  після дітей
це було легко, тому що
діти зазвичай
спали в ліжку, батьки давали мені
багато грошей за перегляд DVD-дисків і
закуски, коли я був ще молодшим, мені
подобалося, коли приходила моя няня,
вона завжди грала в ігри  з нами і
дозволяли нам не спати допізна, вона посилала нас
спати перед тим, як мої батьки повернулися додому. Я
знаю, що в деяких країнах няня не
так поширена, це не є частиною культури, я
вважаю, що це не так вже й погано, я
читав  багато в т  він зараз пише про те, що
няні б'ють дітей, тому що
вони не сплять, це дуже погано, добре,
хлопці, тому ви читаєте підказки
під динаміком, і я сподіваюся, що ви заповнили
всі пропуски правильними словами,
тепер наступне завдання буде таким же  завдання,
але воно буде трохи іншим,
добре, подивіться, текст той самий,
але чи можете ви виправити написання
слів добре, ми дамо вам кілька
моментів, щоб виправити написання, тож
, будь ласка, не поспішайте прочитати його
один раз  знову і задихатися або, можливо, ти знаєш
ці слова після того, як прослухаєш його після того,
як прослухаєш цей текст кілька
разів, так що ваш час
і добре, хлопці, я розкрию відповіді,
і я буду читати разом з вами добре,
я любив няні, коли я був молодшим
це був дуже простий спосіб заробити гроші,
все, що мені потрібно було зробити, це сидіти в будинку мого сусіда
і доглядати за дітьми,
тому що діти зазвичай
спали в ліжку, батьки давали
мені багато грошей за перегляд DVD  і
їсти закуски, коли я був ще молодшим, мені
подобалося, коли приходила моя няня,
вона завжди грала з нами в ігри, і
дозволяла нам не спати допізна, вона відправляла нас
спати перед тим, як мої батьки повернулися додому, я
знаю, що в деяких країнах няня є"  Я
так
часто читаю в газетах про те, що
няня б'є дітей,
тому що вони не сплять, це дуже
погано, хлопці, тому ми слухали і
читали  напишіть кілька разів, чи можете ви
відповісти на запитання, то чому
автору дуже сподобалося няні, тому йому сподобалося
няні, тому що це був дуже простий
спосіб заробити гроші, і наступне запитання,
що він повинен був зробити, добре,
ваша відповідь, тому він мав сидіти в своєму
сусідський будинок і доглядай за дітьми,
чому це було так легко, це було легко, тому
що діти зазвичай лежали в ліжках,
і що було такого веселого в цій роботі, що
батьки давали гроші на перегляд DVD і
перекуси чому це тому, що
діти були здорові  Аді в ліжку, який
досвід автора в дитинстві мав
няню, він каже, що йому дуже
сподобалося, коли його няня приходила,
тому що вони зазвичай гралися і
не лягали спати рано, і автор знає,
що няня не поширена в
різних країнах, але  погана
сторона няні та погана
сторона няні полягає в тому, що іноді
няня жарить дітей, тому що
вони не сплять добре, хлопці, це було
якось незвично для вас сьогодні, коли
ми чудово попрацювали над читанням та
зануренням у  тема вакансії для
підлітків, як ви виконуєте домашнє завдання.
Я б прошу, щоб ви перейшли за цим посиланням і
виконали завдання на аудіювання, подібне до того, що ми виконали
з додатковими вправами на
співбесіді,
чи пам'ятаєте ви два уроки тому, у нас був
урок співбесіди,
тож давайте  згадайте і попрацюйте ще
трохи над цією темою, ця річ буде
прикріплена під відео на YouTube,
слідкуйте за нею та виконуйте деякі завдання, хлопці,
було весело бути з вами сьогодні, і я сподіваюся,
що це я  інформація дійсно
необхідна та весела.